[Music]
hey what is up guys I'm conveyed to be
here and when Apple announced the new
MacBook Pros they also pretty much
killed all hopes for another cinema
display when they dropped this alongside
it the new LG 5k ultra fine display and
then they said they'd be selling
alongside the new Macs in the Apple
store okay we want to give it a chance
so is this if I just cover up the LG
logo is this thing a good enough
replacement for the Apple Cinema Display
legacy is this good enough well I'll be
using it for a couple weeks and my
answer is it depends on who you are
let me explain so I'm coming from a pair
of aces 32 inch 4k monitors I've always
been a dual monitor person and this LG
5k display is awesome I mean it's
objectively undeniably awesome it's a
smaller 27-inch display at 5k so 50 120
by 28 80 which gives you about 218
pixels per inch which is awesome for a
desktop display and it also has the
wider p-3 color gamut so colors really
pop and 500 nits of brightness so it's
vivid contrast II and clear there's a
1201 contrast ratio so it's just
obviously a really great looking panel
that's what you like to see the expects
on the site also say it's anti glare but
the Asus was way more math than this
this is much more glossy so if you
position yourself near Windows you'll
have to know where the lights are going
to be behind you but once you get used
to that that's pretty much fun and then
the actual hardware around the monitor
itself is pretty good I mean some people
have said it's not the prettiest thing
in the world but you got a
height-adjustable stand here it's tilted
just about - one thing it doesn't do is
swivel I think it would have been super
easy to put a swivel right here in the
base but it doesn't do that and then you
can see the bezels obviously some people
been talking about how it's not the
prettiest thing in the world I'd agree
it's got a little bit of a bigger
forehead than a chin but to be honest
I've barely noticed that after like a
week of using the monitors you're not
really looking at the bezels anymore
after like a couple of days but the
larger top bezel does also hold the
webcam and microphone which are also
actually pretty good and this guy also
has speakers right on the bottom the
grills on the bottom - they're
downward-facing big sound just like the
IMAX speakers is pretty comparable to
that the overall still pretty well I
mean it's not metal like you see the
exposed metal on the iMac you get metal
down here on the stand but once you get
into the plastic of the tops it doesn't
quite feel the same but you're not
really paying that much attention to
that one that
you look so good the rest can be kind of
forgiven so the other thing is this
monitor is also made for Mac they're
selling alongside the Macs
it's marketed next to the MacBook Pro
what does that mean for it well first of
all there are no buttons anywhere on the
outside of this thing there's no knobs
or anything for turning on or off no
power button nothing it all goes through
the software in Mac OS 10 so any colors
you want to change any resolution you
want to adjust any brightness changes
they will all happen through the
software just because that's the way it
works with Mac so there's that and then
of course there is the USB type-c the
one single Thunderbolt three table that
I'm plugging this into my macbook pro
with that's a pretty big deal so through
this one cable you're getting video
going from the computer to the monitor
and you're also getting power going back
from the monitor to the computer so it's
actually charging my macbook pro with
the same cable that's doing this video
which is pretty awesome it saves you a
port you don't have to plug into the
wall anymore for the most part that's
really convenient and then around the
back there's a three port USB type-c hub
on back the monitor it's not full
Thunderbolt 3 and it's not even fully
powered USB 3.1 but it's a couple of
solid USB 3 ports for stuff like media
card readers webcams etc and this again
freeze-up ports on the laptop if you'd
normally put say an SD card reader in
this laptop you can now put it on the
back of the monitor so overall it seems
like an ideal package you know it's one
laptop one display one cable between
them nice and clean and you get way more
working area in this glorious 5 klg
panel looking good but obviously it's
not quite perfect for everyone if you're
a person who doesn't have a 2016-2017
MacBook Pro then this is probably not a
good pick because even with the right
adapter the highest resolution you can
get out of this monitor even with a Mac
Pro is about 4k with one cable so not
ideal it's still going to be a beautiful
colorful contrasting monitor but it's
only 4k and you'd bought a 5k display
you might as well get your money's worth
and then number two if you edit video on
your laptop which again not a lot of
people do but if you're in that category
you might not be able to get away with
using just the power cable from the
monitor here's a fun story I tweeted
about already when I was editing video
in Final Cut Pro with this MacBook Pro
plugged in to the monitor getting
battery it says it's charging the whole
time and while I'm editing the battery
life still decreases from 100% going
down while it's still plugged in so I'm
plugged in and charging and I get to 85
percent and 75 percent and 50 percent I
get all the way to rendering the whole
video out and right when the video is
done rendering my laptop says it has 4
percent battery even though it's still
plugged in and charging obviously that's
not a normal use case most people aren't
editing heavy high-resolution videos on
their MacBook Pros I get it but you
should know that this monitor is not
delivering necessarily the entire 85
watts of power necessary to keep this
thing fully charged it even says 85
watts on the site and when I go into
system profiler it says it's getting 85
watts but Dave 2d tested at any tweeted
I mean that he tested it and II was
getting something more like 60 to 62
watts
so again if you're editing with video
you're probably gonna have to unplug one
of the monitors and plug in the power
brick to get your full power again
that's not your normal customer if your
setup is near a router like within two
to three feet of a Wi-Fi router you
probably want to temporarily avoid this
monitor due to poor shielding there's
been reports of flickering and weird non
responsiveness and rebooting of the
monitor when it's really close to a
router now I don't have that problem on
the way on the other side over there but
if you have a router that's really close
to your setup probably going to want to
avoid that LG says they're working on
updating this version to have improved
shielding and they're even okay to
retrofit these monitors that don't have
good shielding with new ones but until
then I just give it a second because
that doesn't seem like a very good
property to have but even after all of
that other than that the monitor the
monitor right here is really good it's
amazing I wish I could say it's like an
Apple logo away from being like the next
cinema display but obviously it's not
quite there my setup where I'm using is
I have two of these attached to the
macbook pro that I'm using all three
screens full-time and even I've had
little blinking problems that a reboot
eventually fixed but it's like I
shouldn't even be having this problem so
I think if you have a MacBook Pro a new
MacBook Pro and you just want one
monitor to plug in with one cable to
sell your desk and just get way more
real estate then this is an awesome pick
the panel is amazing it's way more
pixels it looks fantastic
and it is excellent for people who are
in that sort of a casual user even
though you're buying a MacBook Pro you
can still get a lot casually out of this
monitor if you fit into any of those
buckets of people I described earlier
then you may want to hold off on this or
maybe look at the 4k version okay
overall conclusion is the panel
obviously is really good it's beautiful
vivid vibrant love it the hardware
surround
the panel is sort of hit or miss for
some people it's alright you know I like
the understated design but some people
might not like it as much and then the
compatibility or just knowing if you fit
in those buckets of people I talked
about is what's going to decide if you
buy this monitor or not so that's pretty
much it it's you could say it's ultra
fine thanks for watching and I'll talk
to you guys the next one pace
[Music]